ladies and gentlemen now we're gonna do
a fun little comedy bit in just a second
but first we have to take care of a
little business up top okay
now folks if you're looking for the
finest in kitchen and bathroom cleansers
your search is over
reach for scrub a dub that's right don't
just clean your kitchen or bathroom
scrub a dub it with scrub a dub and if
you don't believe me
just ask the man on the bottle himself
isn't that right scrub it up
that's right Conan if there's one thing
I love it's cleaning so watch out dirt
because scrub Adele's coming
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's right scrub a dub okay thank you
very much now Andy let me ask you a
quick question what's getting this one
bit you ever noticed that a lot of
celebrities bear a resemblance to
certain animals oh I think everybody has
okay yeah this is fun well we thought
it'd be fun to show some celebrities and
their animal counterparts for example I
got one Pamela Lee is like a fox because
I want to have sex with her all right
scrub a dub that's fine okay we we did
your advertisement so justjust can you
leave now all right
Campbell ELISA Fox all right that that's
enough please okay let's get into this
now uh uh-oh do you ever notice that
Keanu Reeves looks a little bit like a
fruit bat really yeah
he looks like a flick and we thought
that Lucky seven pay off you suckers oh
hold on a second what are you doing
scrub a dub you know how it is Conan
scrub it up just looking for a little
extra cab money for the right oh yeah
why would you just I I want you to get
out of the studio right now okay
typical Catholic what did you say I'm
going I'm going
all right I'm sorry all right let's get
back into this one anyway we were
wondering what if Sigourney Weaver all
right you know did she bear any
resemblance at all - a giant gar okay
that's something that we're that would
mean what is that
what now you can't spray paint that word
on our set get off my ass O'Brien okay
look look I want him out of here now
okay would you just get out of here I
have worked way too hard to make the
show a nice Pleasant place a nice show
people to watch you know what I mean I'm
gonna be damned if I let some
androgynous spokesperson ruin it now
let's just just get out of here fine in
the greenroom
yeah but bring these people in and they
think that they can just come to our
show
wait a minute
hold on what is going on are you gonna
call me scrubs sure scrub a dub we'll
call you baby what we mean what you're
having sex with an audience member
believe me it's the most fun this
audience has enjoyed the entire show
all right forget it doesn't that just
transit security
let's get security in here getting out
of here right now
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right everybody I'm sorry yeah we'll
be right back with Chris Kattan nothing
like that
[Applause]
[Music]